las calles siguen incendiadas en varias
regiones de Irán y la furia no da signos
de disminuir tras la muerte de maxa Mini
bajo custodia policial Pues a la brutal
represión de las fuerzas de seguridad
que deja al menos 17 muertos Pero serían
muchos más según la ongs
es un incidente que está siendo
investigado y que se atribuye a lo que
le ocurrió a la dama lo que se está
hablando hoy de lo que se ha hablado con
respecto a su muerte si hay una parte
culpable ciertamente debe ser
investigada me puse en contacto con su
familia La familia de la difunta les
asegure personalmente que continuaremos
firmemente investigando ese incidente
desde Nueva York que el presidente
iranía amenazó que los actos de Caos no
son aceptables como advertencia a los
manifestantes que están en las calles a
mini murió el pasado 13 de septiembre
luego de ser detenida por la temida
policía de la moral iraní por llevar mal
el hillab obligatorio para las mujeres
en la nación islámica los uniformados
alegan que la joven falleció por
cardíaco algo que la familia niega
rotundamente asegurando que la joven
tenía signos de maltrato y acusan a la
policía de haberla golpeado en la cabeza
con una porra lo que le habría causado
la muerte
las causas precisas y las circunstancias
de la muerte no están claras lo que está
claro es que fue detenida y tratada en
violación de los Derechos Humanos más
básicos el incidente también pone de
relieve los abusos sufridos por mujeres
y niñas en todo el mundo la indignación
de las tiranía está traspasado fronteras
y las manifestaciones en rechazo a la
obligatoriedad del velo islámico y en
apoyo a las mujeres iraníes se están
dando en diversos países con activistas
incendiando el hillab cortándose el
cabello en pro de la libertad de la
iraníes